[Música]
[Aplausos]
de las cinco mayores economías del mundo
una en concreto es fundamentalmente una
potencia marítima sí obviamente hablamos
de nijón de Japón la peculiaridad de
Japón Además de que se trata de un
archipiélago es que sus mares
territoriales y sus aguas interiores
suman más superficie que la que tienen
Tierra Firme hablamos de unos
430.000 kilómetros cuadrados versus algo
menos de 380.000 y por supuesto a ello
tendríamos que sumarle la zona económica
exclusiva esto es aquellas aguas que no
forman parte estrictamente de un país
pero sobre las que este tiene derechos
especiales a la hora de explotar sus
recursos una zona que según la
convención de Naciones Unidas sobre el
derecho del mar se extiende 200 millas
náuticas desde la costa En definitiva
que Japón tiene mucho muchísimo más mar
que tierra que defender
[Música]
y eso no es todo al margen de la mera
geografía si nos fijamos En dónde está
concentrada la población japonesa
veremos que aproximadamente la mitad de
sus 126 millones de habitantes viven
próximos a sus 35.000 kilómetros de
línea de Costa todo esto hace de Japón
un país esencialmente echado al mar un
país que tanto para su economía como
para su propia defensa Mira sobre todo a
las aguas marinas es decir que no solo
hablamos ni mucho menos de una cuestión
geográfica sino sobre todo de una
económica y militar
más del 99% del comercio internacional
de Japón se lleva a cabo por barco esto
incluye el 80% de toda la energía y el
99% del petróleo que consumen en otras
palabras sin unos bares seguros o que
estén Bajo su control o el de sus
aliados toda la economía impona estaría
expuesta a una enorme vulnerabilidad y
ojo porque tal y como veremos Esta es la
idea que determina en gran medida todos
los planes de seguridad del país del sol
naciente aquí el mar vale doble
[Música]
y claro pensando un momento ya os hemos
contado aquí en visualpolitik como china
está construyendo la mayor flota Naval
del mundo por número de buques y también
nos hemos contado como las ambiciones de
Pekín pasan precisamente por controlar
los mares que le rodean y evidentemente
eso es algo que tiene muchas
implicaciones para sus países vecinos
entre ellos el propio Japón 3 de
noviembre de 2022 la armada de China
marca un ritmo récord de incursiones en
el mar territorial de Japón Los buques
de la armada del ejército Popular de
liberación han entrado en aguas
territoriales japonesas ocho veces desde
el 2004 y 5 de ellas han ocurrido desde
octubre de 2021 con semejante percal no
nos puede extrañar por qué en Japón Esto
está generando cada vez más inquietud y
sabéis que es precisamente por eso por
lo que se están poniendo las pilas
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas En este vídeo os
vamos a contar como ahora Japón parece
decidido a construir una fuerte defensa
aeronaval para proteger sus costas y sus
intereses económicos y territoriales Y
por supuesto también os contaremos
cuáles son sus puntos más débiles
estaremos acaso ante el nuevo despertar
militar del país del sol naciente Hasta
qué punto Japón una gran potencia
económica puede convertirse también en
toda una potencia militar y un actor
clave en Asia Pacífico por qué la fuerza
naval puede ser fundamental a la hora de
garantizar la seguridad de Japón y ojo
que no hablamos solo de china Así que
arranquemos
[Música]
asegurad las líneas
fijaos por un momento En este mapa lo
que estáis viendo son las principales
líneas de comunicación marítimas las
conocidas como slok por sus siglas en
inglés hablamos de rutas de miles de
millas náuticas por las que pasan no
solo el grueso de las exportaciones e
importaciones de Japón sino también de
algunas de las mayores economías del
mundo como China o Corea del Sur y ojo
porque cuando hablamos de exportaciones
e importaciones o solo nos referimos a
bienes de consumo sino también y quizás
todavía más importante aquí post
industriales y suministros energéticos
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea
aproximadamente la mitad de todo el gas
natural licuado que importa Japón pasa
Por alguno de los hotspots de los puntos
calientes que tienen las slot que hemos
visto en este mapa especialmente
importante son las zonas del estrecho de
ormuz del estrecho de malaca y del
estrecho de Taiwán y ojo porque hablamos
de volúmenes enormes con algo más de 74
millones de toneladas al año japonés por
ejemplo el segundo mayor importador de
gas natural licuado de todo el mundo
justo por detrás de China que se situó
lo más alto del podio en 2021
[Música]
Y eso si hablamos del gas Porque si
hablamos del petróleo entonces la
importación de estos hotspots marinos es
mucho mayor el 90% de todo el petróleo
que importa Japón procede de oriente
medio Sí sí el 90%, Así que tiene que
cruzar todos esos puntos calientes donde
puede pasar de todo y crece nada bueno
por ejemplo el estrecho de ormuz que
separa emiratos árabes Unidos y omán de
Irán tiene en algunos puntos menos de 34
kilómetros de ancho y esto se vuelve
todavía más importante Cuando tenemos en
cuenta el hecho de que hablamos de una
zona especialmente tensa por las
amenazas e incluso ataques y asaltos que
recurrentemente Irán comete contra
buques mercantes 13 de junio de 2019 un
buque japonés es atacado cerca del
estrecho de ormuz Estados Unidos culpa
Irán 4 de enero del 2021 untarquero
surcoreano es incautado por Irán en el
estrecho de ormuz estos titulares son
tan sólo dos ejemplos pero la lista es
larga muy larga y de hecho este tipo de
tensión lejos de disminuir parece que
puede ir a más
Así que como os podéis imaginar las
operaciones militares de los países más
interesados en asegurar sus líneas de
suministro se Están volviendo bastante
frecuentes en estas zonas especialmente
en lo que respecta a la escolta de
barcos un buque de guerra japonés parte
hacia el golfo para patrullar las rutas
de suministro de petróleo miles de
barcos japoneses navegan esas aguas del
Golfo cada año incluyendo buques que
transportan el 90% de nuestro petróleo
es la línea de vida de Japón antiguo
Primer Ministro japonés infoab en la
base naval de yokozuka cerca de Tokio el
problema amigos es que si pensáis que
después de pasar el estrecho de ormuz ya
todo es pan comido ciento decepcionados
pero este es muy equivocados después de
conseguir cruzar sanos y salvos esta
zona Los buques llenos de gas natural
licuado petróleo o mercancías que van
hacia Japón y Corea tienen que
enfrentarse a una segunda zona caliente
los mares del sudeste asiático unos
mares donde el riesgo es doble hablamos
de China y también de piratas
hace poco en nuestro canal hermano
visual economic si no lo conoces mereces
tarjeta amarilla os hablamos sobre la
piratería y especialmente sobre los
piratas de somalia si aún no lo habéis
visto pero os interesa el mundo de la
economía No olvides echarle un vistazo
el enlace abajo como siempre El caso es
que si os preguntara Cuál es la zona del
planeta que más sufre la piratería y el
secuestro de barcos seguramente muchos
me responderíais que sin duda se trata
de la zona del cuerno de África en el
entorno precisamente De somalia verdad
vamos seguro que todos tenemos ahora
mismo en mente la película del Capitán
Phillips de Tom hanks cierto pues no lo
siento pero no error gran error es
cierto que en la zona del cuerno de
África estuvo la cuna de la piratería
moderna sin embargo la región con más
piratas y que concentra cerca del 60% de
todos los casos actualmente se sitúa en
el sudeste asiático cómo te quedas
especialmente hablamos de de los
estrechos de malaca y de sunda y de las
zonas próximas a las costas de Vietnam
de Camboya de Indonesia y de Malasia
estos son los puntos más calientes pero
es que incluso al norte de Taiwán se han
llegado a registrar ataques y si le
echáis un vistazo de nuevo al mapa de
las slock que os pusimos antes veréis
que por ahí también pasan las
principales rutas de importación y
exportación de Japón y Corea del Sur
obviamente esto obliga a desplegar en la
zona un nivel extra de seguridad lo que
se suele lograr gracias a la
colaboración internacional de los países
interesados y de los países soberanos de
las aguas el problema Pues que muchos de
estos países del sudeste asiático
todavía no tienen armadas fuertes ni
recursos suficientes con los que
asegurar sus mares Así que la gran
responsabilidad recae en los propios
países interesados en proteger el
tráfico marítimo lo que incluye a China
y a Estados Unidos pero para países como
Japón eso puede no ser suficiente
a Tokio no le hace ninguna pero que
ninguna gracia que la seguridad de sus
suministros pase por la buena voluntad
de chiquinpin y es por ese motivo que
poco a poco este país ha tratado de ir
desarrollando una ambiciosa política de
defensa naval
en 1981 el Primer Ministro 5 Suzuki
implantó la llamada política de defensa
de ruta marítimas de las mil millas
básicamente esta política consiste en
que Los buques militares japoneses se
reservan el derecho a intervenir para
proteger sus intereses comerciales en un
área de hasta 1000 millas náuticas de
distancia del territorio japonés Esto es
lo que explica en parte porque Japón ha
puesto tanto empeño en hacer
reclamaciones territoriales de Islas
lejanas algunas a prioridad
Aparentemente absurdas Pues bien con
ello lo que buscan es alejar lo más
posible esa línea de defensa marítima al
mismo tiempo que intentan legitimarla de
algún modo
Y eso queridos amigos amigas es lo que
explica noticias como esta
3 de febrero de 2016 Japón gastará
millones en diminutas Islas mil millas
al sur de Tokio El problema es que
debido a sus históricas reticencias a la
hora de construir unas fuerzas armadas
grandes Japón no tiene capacidad
suficiente como para hacer valer esa
política Así que en la práctica china ha
seguido ganando terreno durante todos
estos años
[Música]
para colmo una de las excusas de China
para expandirse por el mar de la China
meridional y sus alrededores es
precisamente el agresivo planteamiento
de defensa marítima de Japón que hace
que las zonas de interés de uno y otro
país se solapen el resultado es que a
medida que china ha ido modernizando sus
fuerzas armadas y construyendo la mayor
armada del planeta la inquietud y la
tensión de Tokio ha ido creciendo más y
más y especialmente tras la cada vez
mayor ambición de Pin en ese sentido la
toma de Hong Kong y la constante
hostilidad sobre Taiwán han sido
Auténticos puntos de inflexión para el
gobierno japonés Un gobierno que empieza
a tener auténtico pavor determinar
siendo en la práctica un país satélite O
al menos un país sometido a los
designios de Pekín y justo aquí llegamos
a la tercera clave que explica por qué
Japón tiene entre Ceja y fija volver a
convertirse en una superpotencia naval
[Música]
Y es que veréis el estrecho de Taiwán es
probablemente la zona militarmente más
tensa de los mares de Asia Oriental
hablamos de un estrecho que es
particularmente relevante para Japón por
dos motivos el primero es que Taiwán es
un país que literalmente está bajo la
protección implícita de Japón ya os lo
hemos contado en un pasado vídeo los
intereses económicos y estratégicos de
Japón en Taiwán son enormes Así que su
estabilidad es clave o solo en términos
políticos sino también para las propias
empresas japonesas el segundo motivo
tiene que ver con lo mismo que venimos
insistiendo en este vídeo la larga ruta
de suministros y mercancías entre Japón
Europa y Oriente medio también pasa por
el entorno de Taiwán En otras palabras
virtualmente toda la economía japonesa
depende de la estabilidad de una serie
de zonas que se están convirtiendo en
todo un polvorín de tensiones y amenazas
en otras palabras que la mayor amenaza
para Japón no es ni mucho menos que un
buen día china que hiciera desatar una
guerra o de este país no la mayor
amenaza tiene mucho que ver con la cada
vez mayor capacidad de Pekín para
estrangular presionar y coaccionar a
Japón Así que con todo esto en cuenta la
pregunta es muy clara Qué opciones
tienen los japoneses para proteger su
economía sus líneas de suministro y la
propia integridad del país
[Música]
Pues por un lado incrementar y
profundizar sus alianzas internacionales
Qué es precisamente lo que está haciendo
con Estados Unidos con Reino Unido con
la India con Australia incluso con Corea
del Sur 6 de septiembre de 2022 Corea
del Sur y japonés establecieron las
primeras conversaciones militares de
alto nivel en 6 años 8 de septiembre de
2022 indie Japón realizarán más
ejercicios militares para estrechar
lazos 23 de octubre de 2022 Japón y
Australia refuerzan su pacto de
seguridad frente a la amenaza china 5 de
noviembre de 2022 Japón firma un pacto
militar con el Reino Unido ante la
amenaza china pero ahí No termina todo
por otro lado la opción es reconstruir
su armada y volver a convertirse en una
gran potencia marítima con el auge de
china en la región Ya no les queda otra
si no quieren terminar convirtiéndose en
un país vasallo y sabéis que en Japón en
Japón lo saben el nuevo libro blanco de
defensa de Japón de 2022 exige un
impulso militar masivo para
contrarrestar a China Exacto Japón
quiere rearmarse a toda velocidad y
quiere hacerlo sobre todo por el mar y
por la tecnología balística dicho esto
queréis saber más detalles sobre los
planes de Japón Para volver a
convertirse en toda una potencia militar
Pues bien veámoslo
El regreso del sol naciente
Japón está de vuelta en el campo militar
eso eso es algo que ya no se puede negar
y tal y como os estamos contando de todo
el gasto que se va a llevar a cabo para
reforzar las capacidades militares la
conocida como fuerza marítima de
autodefensa y la fuerza aérea se van a
llevar la mayor parte es decir el
objetivo será crear una nueva fuerza
aeronaval capaz de defender los
intereses de Japón en toda la región
siendo mucho menos dependientes de
Estados Unidos y siendo incluso capaces
de rivalizar con china Ese es el
objetivo ahora bien de qué estamos
hablando exactamente
pues veréis Japón tiene la intención de
gastar algo más de 300.000 millones de
dólares Durante los próximos cinco años
en sus fuerzas armadas de este modo
pretende gastar al menos el 2% del pib
en defensa cuando hasta ahora duras
penas llegaban al 1%. con este plan los
convertirán en el tercer país de todo el
mundo con mayor presupuesto militar tan
solo por detrás de Estados Unidos y de
China
todo un giro a décadas de política
militar de momento el gobierno japonés
no ha presentado un plan integral Claro
que nos diga cuáles serán todas sus
prioridades sin embargo ya se están
comenzando a anunciar algunos proyectos
por ejemplo tenemos el caso de dos
Destructores con capacidades de defensa
contra misiles balísticos en los que
Japón ha invertido unos
7.100 millones de dólares eso eso son
muchos yukichis y no sé así dicho puede
parecer poca cosa dos barcos más sin
embargo la realidad es muy diferente
[Música]
cuando os entreguen serán los
destructores más grandes de Japón y dos
de los más grandes de todas las aguas de
Asia hablamos de 20.000 toneladas de
peso cada uno y 210 metros de largo
estos buques que se espera que sean
entregados en torno al año 2027
Instagram además equipados con el más
avanzado sistema de combate aegis con
misiles interceptores sm3 que a día de
hoy Son la crème de la crema en su clase
Y por supuesto Esta no es la única
novedad Japón pone en servicio la
primera nueva fragata multipropósito de
clase mogami el kumano es el primero de
los 22 buques planificados de la clase
que incluirá capacidades nunca antes
vistas en una fragata japonesa De hecho
son este nuevo grupo de fragatas las que
Japón utilizará en misiones de
vigilancia marítima dentro y fuera de
Japón incluido en la zona del mar de la
china meridional donde somos contado que
hay tantos problemas pero todavía
podemos encontrar más novedades
[Música]
por ejemplo Japón anunció en marzo de
2022 que al igual que hizo con el primer
buque iniciará los trabajos para
convertir el segundo destructor
multipropósito de la clase izumo en un
portaaviones de esta forma los dos
barcos de esta clase Se convertirán en
los primeros portaaviones con bandera
japonesa desde la época Imperial estos
portaaviones operarán además 42 cajas de
quinta generación f-35b con despegue
vertical se usarán para disuadir a China
de realizar incursiones aéreas tanto en
Japón como los cielos de sus aliados
además sumados a los f-35a que Japón ya
tiene o que están pedidos el país
operará la friolera de 147 de estos
aparatos de aquí a unos pocos años será
la segunda mayor flota de f-35 tan solo
por detrás de Estados Unidos
como os podéis imaginar todo esto junto
a los drones global haw estadounidenses
y dos nuevos aviones cisterna para
repostaje Boeing kace46a le va a
proporcionar a los nipones una capacidad
de defensa aeronaval muy pero que muy
importante
[Música]
Y eso eso no es todo recientemente ha
saltado esta noticia 9 de diciembre de
2022 Japón Gran Bretaña Italia planean
un avión de combate de sexta generación
para rivalizar con los aviones de guerra
más avanzados del mundo Japón Reino
Unido Italia desarrollarán conjuntamente
y con el respaldo de los Estados Unidos
un avión de combate de Última Generación
para completar sus flotas de f-35 y
superar ampliamente las capacidades
militares de China y de Rusia Ese es el
objetivo que estos tres países han hecho
público un acuerdo al que pronto podrían
sumarse más países y es que de hecho Los
japoneses quieren llevar su rearme tan
lejos Que incluso se plantean
desarrollar un misil hipersónico Sí sí
un misil hipersónico que entraría en
servicio para el año 2030 3 de noviembre
de 2022 Japón valora desplegar un misil
hipersónico para el año 2030 para
impulsar la disosión impresionante no os
parece estamos hablando de Japón los que
nos desde hace tiempo o que os interesan
estos temas ya sabéis de que Japón desde
la Segunda Guerra Mundial siempre ha
sido reacio a todos por el tema militar
y no solo por el espíritu Pacífico que
recoge su Constitución sino también por
una especie de convicción social
Pero ya se ha terminado las reglas del
juego han cambiado con el auge militar
de china con una Corea del Norte que no
deja de provocar con misiles cada vez
más avanzados y con una Rusia que se
dedica a invadir otros países y no
olvidéis como detalle que Japón y Rusia
hacen prácticamente frontera y que
tienen una disputa territorial abierta
sobre las Islas kuriles
[Música]
Japón acaba de aprobar su nueva
estrategia de defensa la cual incluye
entre otras cosas la capacidad de
realizar contrataques contra bases
militares en el extranjero además
descarta ir más allá en el futuro e
incluir la posibilidad de realizar
ataques preventivos algo difícilmente
encajable en su marco legal sin una
reforma de la Constitución una reforma
que cada vez tiene más partidarios en la
política japonesa
16 de diciembre de 2022 Japón aprueba la
capacidad de atacar bases enemigas en un
importante cambio de política de defensa
Así es como están las cosas la pregunta
ahora es para ti crees que Japón
terminará convirtiéndose en toda una
potencia aeronaval capaz de rivalizar de
tú a tú con la mismísima china Pues de
Japón convertirse en la mano derecha de
los Estados Unidos en la región déjanos
tus opiniones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y si te gustó Este vídeo No
te olvides de dar a INE y suscribirte a
nuestro canal Y recuerda que también
puedes apoyarnos activamente sumándote a
nuestra comunidad en patreon os dejamos
el enlace aquí abajo en la descripción
como siempre Domo Arigato por estar ahí
un saludo y mátame
[Música]